hello
and welcome to this session my name is
deborah elkin
and i'm a technical solutions consultant
with google cloud
i'll be presenting this session with
warren vela he's an
enterprising integration architect with
the australian energy market operator
in this session we will see how apis can
help you
unlock the power of your existing data
and how the australian energy market
operator is leveraging
apigee to do so we will also see aimos
apis
in action
we all know that this is the age of
connected experiences
your customers or your customers
customers want to interact with
applications and data in different ways
in different channels on different
platforms these interactions are
constantly changing
and everything is connected with
everything else
apis are key enablers of digital
experiences
think how pervasive google maps are or
how booking systems have made our lives
easier
of course there's data involved in all
digital experiences
whether it be available flights on a
travel booking system
or your bank account details in online
banking or just about anything you can
think of
really however the data you need to
build these digital experiences is
often buried deep within companies
systems of record
it could be in data warehouses data
lakes
files that could be scattered everywhere
disparate systems
legacy systems hard to connect to
this data is most likely locked away
hard to get at
and it takes a lot of time to surface it
so somewhere there is a system of record
holding data that is hard to get at
it can take months or years to make the
changes required to make that data
available
but customer or consumers expectations
are high
they want the digital experience that is
underpinned by that data
and they want it quick this is where api
management fits in
it fills the gap between the systems of
record
and the requirements of new digital
experiences
it helps organizations build a bridge
between legacy systems and modern
applications
and it can build that bridge in a secure
reliable
and scalable way so let's talk about
apigee apigee is google cloud's
api management platform not just an api
gateway
and it gives you all the tools you need
for unlocking your data via
apis apigee enables digital business
acceleration
with a unified and complete platform
purpose built for the digital economy
apigee makes it easier to manage the
entire digital value chain
with api services developer services and
analytics services
let's start at the bottom with api
services
this is the api runtime and mediation
engine
api services lets you manage the
connection between the api consumers
and the back-end service you have
complete control
over the request and the response you
can add security
transform requests and responses
orchestrate
calls across multiple systems impose
rate limits and quotas
and prevent people from abusing your
services
api analytics helps you measure tune
and monitor your api program it enables
end-to-end visibility
across the digital value chain with
developer analytics
operational and business metrics reports
about app performance
and custom reports that you may need all
are necessary to monitor
measure and manage success of your api
program
developer services enable a great
developer and community experience
that accelerates api adoption simplifies
learning and increases the business
value of
apis it provides a developer portal for
your api consumers
along with features for packaging
monetizing your services
and data when you're sharing your data
you want to make sure you do this in a
secure way
when we talk about security there are
many different aspects
for instance data should only reach the
right audience
this is where authentication and
authorization
come in in that respect apigee supports
widely used standards such as oauth and
openid connect
you also don't want anyone snooping
around when the data is in transit
this is where encryption plays a key
role
apigee supports tls mutual tls
and can support different configuration
of these protocols when communicating
with api clients and backend services
that hold the data
for example you may configure one-way
tls on the client
side but mutual tls for one of your
backends
and one way tls for another auditing is
also very important
you need to know who has accessed what
data who has made a change to the api
that exposes that data
apigee auditing and logging capabilities
have recovered
also is the sensitive data no problem
use an apigee extension
to quickly reduct data with gcp data
loss prevention services
you could potentially think of making
money out of your data as well
that is if you wish to of course not all
apis should necessarily be monetized
there are apis that build consumer
experience or drive
indirect value this should be free for
instance think about apis for ticket
booking
finding store locations product
availability etc
on the other hand if your apis help
developers
build apps that generate revenue you may
consider
charging for those apis for example
apis that provide weather data or
messaging services
apigee api monetization offers multiple
options to set up charge plans
you can configure fee based plans volume
based plans
you can set up revenue sharing with
developers freemium models
etc it also allows you to check
monetization plan limits during api
execution in short
whether you want to build new digital
experiences
create a partner ecosystem or apply
artificial intelligence or machine
learning to your data
unlocking your data is the key and apis
are the way to achieve this
we will now see how the australian
energy market operator
is unlocking its data and putting it to
effective work in an
ecosystem i'll now hand over to warren
thank you deb hello my name is warren
vala
and i am the enterprise integration
architect at the australian energy
market operator
today i'd like to talk through how aimo
has partnered with google
and the apogee platform to unlock the
power of our existing data
through apis we'll take a look at who
emo is
some of the unique challenges the energy
industry is facing
and how apis have been instrumental in
our digital transformation
so where does animo sit within the
australian energy market
aimo is responsible for the day-to-day
operations of the australian energy
market which is made up of multiple
markets covering both gas
and electricity on one side aimer
manages the physical nem grid
the transmission network the large
electricity towers that you may have
seen around the country
on the other side aimo operates the
financial energy markets to enable
energy flow
all the way from generation to the
customer households via retailers
as you can see some of the actors in the
energy markets are typical
large-scale generators such as coal
power plants and wind farms
all the way to meter data providers who
are responsible for sending the meter
data from households to aimo
sometimes this is automated via smart
meters and sometimes this is manually
read
one of the biggest shifts we are seeing
in the energy market is the active role
of the customer who is now
also playing a critical part of the grid
especially as power is starting to flow
two way
that's inter houses and now out of
houses
let's take a look at some of the
technology challenges that the energy
industry faces
if we look deeper into the national
electricity market which was built over
20 years ago
the systems are largely connected over
either scada operational systems over
private networks
or market data for example dispatch data
which is an instruction
sent to a generator every five minutes
all bids and offers into the market
which is received from generators and
retailers
is still sent over to aemo via batch
based systems over private networks
with the increase of dr penetration
across australia which is leading the
world
we have a unique opportunity to unlock
the value in our data
over modern protocols
and so what can animo do about this we
have a unique opportunity where we are
seeing an intersection
between the energy industry
transformation and our digital
transformation
and as part of our digital
transformation we are tapping into these
opportunities to enable new channels to
really lower the barrier entry
promoting further competition in the
market and as we digitize our systems
we are looking to foster innovation
within the energy market
especially in the space of distributed
energy more importantly we are seeing
the rise of prosumers who are looking to
take control of their energy profile
and play an active part in this energy
transformation
and so working with apogee has enabled
us to start this journey
as we look to reach a wider audience
our new apogee developer portal arms us
with the tools to create
a world-class developer experience
accelerate
api adoption simplify learning and
increase the business value of our apis
developers are the key consumers of our
apis and we want to provide them with a
great experience
and make it really easy for them to
discover understand
test and get going with our apis from
having an interactive sandbox to test
our apis
to letting developers manage their own
keys and access to the apis
and not necessarily in an open for all
approach but with the right guard rails
that apigee offers
our aperture developer portal has all
the tools the developer needs
to integrate with us let's take a look
at some of our large-scale programs with
opportunities to unlock the value
of our data the energy industry is
moving along with many programs centered
around a common theme in distributed
energy resources
starting with the distributed energy
resource register the dei register
allows registration of ddr assets
sitting behind the meter
for example rooftop solar panels and
household batteries
apis have enabled for this data to be
registered via the existing tools
and mobile applications that
electricians and installers are already
used to
the virtual power plant trial has
started to advance the integration of dr
into the national literacy market
allowing consumers to group together to
become a virtual power plant
apis have enabled for the management of
these vpps especially in the transfer of
telemetry data
and in the space of five minute
settlements the market is moving to more
granular data
and settlement down to five minutes apis
have enabled for a meter data
at five minute resolution to be sent
across the country
to ama's metadata management database
next we'll take a look at the cdr the
cdr is a national legislative program
which is running across multiple
industries
with the energy industry next in line
the cdr aims to give consumers better
access to their own data
and also allows competition by using a
data driven
innovation approach so let's take a look
at how we are using the apigee platform
to support the cdr
as a use case some of the key areas of
why apogee has been selected
was the choice of implementation options
especially with the hybrid option
giving us even more flexibility on where
to host our apis
whether that is in the google cloud
platform or in our private cloud
data sovereignty is especially important
as we operate national critical
infrastructure
and the flexibility of the platform
allows us to host the platform to make
our strict
obligations for the protection of our
data
and so the main focus of the apogee
platform is to manage our externally
facing apis
in the case of the cdp this allows us to
expose data from our metadata management
systems
and like most organizations we have data
spread over multiple cloud platforms
and on-prem systems and apogee allows us
to unify the experience when integrating
with our apis
apigee is truly enabling our digital
transformation
as we renovate our internal systems from
legacy integration protocols
to modern api ecosystems
now we'll take a look at a live demo and
explore how the victorian government
is using our apis to provide a
comparison service for australian
consumers
here we have an example of an external
consumer
the victorian government energy
comparison website who is consuming the
aimo cdp apis
to provide real-time meter data
retrieval from amaze metadata management
systems
and before the cdp apis were available
the end user needed to complete over 10
questions and in some cases a pdf bill
had to be uploaded
now that the api is available the user
only needs to know their national
metering identifier or their nimi and
the data is retrieved live from our api
i'll now hand it over to deb to walk us
through a live demo
the demo we're about to see is from the
point of view of a consumer wanting to
understand
which energy retailer offers the best
rates for the particular
electricity consumption patterns
i start looking around and i find a
public website that has been set up by
the government of victoria australia
when this website was first launched the
website would estimate the energy
consumption pattern
based on a series of answers provided by
the consumer
this was the simplest option but still
required
a lot of information to be provided the
other option was for the consumer to
upload
a pdf copy of the bill
i will now start answering all the
questions i am being asked
after providing this information i also
need to provide
details of my last electricity bill
at this point i can finally see which
rates are the most convenient to my
particular
situation but i had to answer more than
10
questions to get here and still it is
just an estimate
let us now see how apis that expose data
can improve my user experience
as well as provide more accurate results
so let's start again
this time i will choose a different
method for building my energy profile
quick and accurate this looks promising
all i need to provide is anemi this is a
unique identifier for the smart meter
installed in my house i can find it
in my electricity bill this option
is now powered by imo what this
means is that when i click on get my
data this website uses an
ammo api to retrieve the actual energy
consumption for my house in last 12
months
this provides a very accurate picture on
how i consume
energy
voila i can now see the rate space
suited to my household
without having to go through a lengthy
questionnaire i as a consumer
didn't even need to see the raw data
coming back from the api this user
experience is facilitated by the apis
published by imo
looking at amos api portal a developer
can easily find the relevant apis
and understand how to use them
in this demo we can appreciate the
advantages of unlocking data
via apis this is a public government
website
that leverages information held by aimo
to provide a
much better user experience not only are
the suggestions more
accurate to the consumer but also the
consumer can see them
in a couple of clicks thank you for
watching it
so what's next for aemo and apigee
one of our main focus areas is to enable
dr resources to be integrated into the
grid
which will increase api calls to
millions per day
as we start to receive more and more
telemetry data
and for the cdp api we are looking to
expand this service and enable data
service holders
to also provide data via the cdr gateway
model
we are always looking to reduce our
participant onboarding time and pivoting
off our developer portal to provide the
right amount of information
and further reduce the time to first
hello world
and of course our api product portfolio
is expanding as we continue to transform
our systems
as apis become our primary form of
integration
for our critical market systems thank
you for your time
and i'll now hand it back to deb for
some closing remarks
thank you warren today we looked at how
apis can be used to securely expose your
data
and how the australian energy market
operator is doing this
we want to thank you for watching this
session and if you'd like to continue
the conversation
we have set up some expert 101 sessions
over the next couple of weeks
and of course we will also be answering
questions you submit in the question and
answer section
for this session thank you
you